oops sorry welcome to this blitz video
against oak South Africa right yo okay
Queens gambit declined an evergreen
opening really this is probably still
going to be played when we are dead and
gone and all time popular opening yeah
Bishop f4 against I bd7 a hip like
normally just takes your form it's a
little bit difficult to do something
else but he proves me wrong okay yeah
now I can actually damage blacks pawn
structure and I'm going to do that it is
some an opportunity I should not pass on
however how am I going to play now an
interesting interesting question the d5
pawn is we can do I want to play with
III armed with g3 hmm queen bee three is
also move just attacking this yeah I'm
going to do it with III I'm not sure I
can always play Bishop to f3 if I want
to pressurize the d5 pawn I wonder if
Bishop g4 is a move in this position
yeah but taking on f3 is something that
I really don't mind of course he has
some and I can I can just do those moves
many useful moves I can still play a
look FC one and possibly eight for
trying to attack a check this annoyed it
look see one oh yeah that looks nice and
then a four a five or pieces are
positioned okay i can think about the
knight on f3 I wonder maybe 92 and
Bishop f3 is a good regrouping let's do
that he can play Knight c4 in this
position
maybe do that tickle tickle em a little
bit on the airport and I can actually
play be three if I want to just prevent
this this idea one night a four-night a4
is an interesting move actually 94 I can
take and play Knight b6 let's do that
it's a simple clean simple move queen
bee three was also interesting but he
has 94 then now okay that that this is
the problem is with this structure here
the double pawns okay it's surprising
rook takes Knight b6 then the night is
very nice they're thinking here 96 would
be good probably i'm wrong
I was thinking that this was good but
the truth so it's not not so great
actually yes Brooks is six down hmm why
that wasn't was weird we had idea hmm
that'd be six look c6 and I don't have a
good move somewhere i was thinking like
this isn't possible don't know why
actually ok I have to I have to put it
on b6 there is no no huge alternative
queen 85 Quincy 7
yeah wow I wanted to hear I was really
really a viet react play I was really
thinking that that this is not possible
at all this D takes I don't know why
kind of a brain slipper so that looks
totally ridiculous what I've done ah
come on let's see how bad that is the
structure with the doll porn was really
awkward for black but I night a floor
was was really bad maybe I get an A for
now that that would make things much
better yeah him I know he has some has
the capture but I really cannot oh this
is actually ok now for ok my position is
getting better in what might come to see
six and one day but it is that is kind
kind of a long journey and if not I'm
I'm okay I'm really okay what is my idea
to play here okay five hook a one is one
idea on 92 F 1 III has also a good way
to do it let's do that and i have i have
ketchup on the clock Wow
catch up I've caught up on the clock so
SS nice now put the night over to e3
rook is seven also was a move but I
didn't it doesn't do much ok yeah this
was a possibility of course now I have
to go back looking at this week e5
square so always have to be flexible if
I go f3 what is he doing 92 maybe I can
also take the night I look a 7s control
ok 747 that is a nice nice IDM Queen f8
however I Queen f8 as a more attacking
f2 and the Queen that's kind of awkward
that's awkward ok it didn't do didn't do
anything with it ok let's let's get rid
of the night it might come I mean no 92
listed to move 9290 6593 this may be
possible so anyway here queen to d6
looks good right just entering here
possibly rook aah coming this kind of
ideas okay six also maybe he still
complain I'd be 393 route a 69 txt for
what a shame hmm I can hardly believe it
here I should be some kind of tactic I
mean I also attacked d5 time I just if I
just play okay come on I have to play
quickly maybe I can just take d5 the
next month I don't really see how he
covers it look do you wanna look strange
but if I can just take the five it
doesn't matter queen is seven maybe yeah
but then Quincy six Quincy six still the
text g5 and I bloggers kind of kind of
firm overloaded I hope exists I didn't
see that move awkward 95-96 is not
working so i got got to go here right b5
is also hanging so might be five simply
he has five seconds left this is helping
a bit come again i can take the required
black resigns yeah okay there was a
lucky winner had some kind of weird
hallucination here really kind of
strange I mean here this is a position
where white is just very comfortable he
has this long term weaknesses and I can
I can play this on forever and ever
ever and torture him um I really had a
weird idea here I should just play a
normal move one move that comes into
consideration he is it's a is b3 just
taking away a square what did however
does it we can see three and the Queen
Seidel but it's not totally clear if
this is so great it can play here for
example so probably a move sorry like
this is an idea it's also something that
I initially considered the idea is
simply take it and it like goes forward
I can just step step back and the idea
is to kind of double here then play be
391 looks passive but it's just a
temporary thing he's sitting on the
weaknesses so I don't really need to
rush things but this is a weird idea I
was somehow somehow convinced that he
has to take with the rook here I don't
know why really don't know either we had
idea that I don't know this is details
would not work due to Knight b6 but this
is nonsensical of course and he I have
to this is a bad idea I mean I was kind
of insisting on on my 96 move but it
just loses time i'm kinda lucky that I'm
not immediately am immediately losing
here or anything and now a for ya oh he
can play a five I was thinking I could
this I mean of course I'm just losing a
piece here oh wow oh what a game may I
mean I was I was totally irritated at
this moment because of my we're tonight
a4 b6 ideas they just wins with a five
us I was completely forgetting that this
is a piece up for like and he p as well
otherwise he would have played a five
yes so he made me kind of believe me or
I don't know yeah and now now white is
better yeah things have have changed now
I have the a fall and have his pawn
securely blockaded
and from here it's it's getting down
helium it's amazing yeah I wanted to go
f1 III pressure rise to five but here I
decided to switch back I can also play a
4 here it's not bad at all this is not
not a bad idea either just use the
central the central files I was thinking
Queen f8 might be a move attacking here
on f2 can check here but I have this
move here for Luke Luke 287 that's very
good for wide ok take take take take no
I'd played f3 answers also should be ok
it's very awkward he's just sitting on
weaknesses rookie one immediately has
suggested by the engine you get to the
same position right here white is
Winningham ok now played a very shaky
game that the beginning it was ok in the
later stages but not very well in them
in them outside the opening ok it was
interesting thanks for watching